we were at a crossing
can you feel this can you touch the fear
and dizziness
of our moment can you sense the ground
shifting beneath you the sky spinning as
a red tail swipes the stars from the
heavens
everything is changing right now
there's no going back anymore
all is getting shaky but all is getting
clamped down
all is being liberated while all is
being tracked
all is permitted while the inquisitor
looms behind you
two sides have risen insuperable
opposites
with no median to join them
the extremes are weighing in and all
reality is
caught between charybdis and cilla
you see they told us the world was just
a cacophony of colliding particles
that love was just an injection of
hormones and instincts
they told us the heavens were cold and
dead
that the fairies were ancestors
delusions
they convinced us art was the framing of
random facts
and objects they told us our stories and
rituals were only
power games and superstitions
they made us into desire machines
no closer to the gods than the beasts
in fact the gods do not exist
the angels the jinns the demons the
woodland
sprites do not exist
there's superstition the world is a
wound-up
clock running out and in the end
you are a wound-up clock running out
into nothingness
you can't try to kill all the gods
and then still expect to live can you
they mocked they derided they dissected
and now our world is being ripped apart
now
who could have seen this coming
who could have thought that in defiling
our stories
and demonizing our orders and reducing
all that made us
one to the quantities that embodied that
unity
who would have thought that that would
fragment us
that it would fragment our societies our
vision
that it would twist our virtues
into innumerable empty desires but this
is where we
stand isn't it
we look around us and we watch the story
unravel we watch our commonalities fall
apart
as people are at each other's throats
first virtually but more and more
in the flesh
and so what can we do
we're supposed to be artists
but it's partly our fault that this has
happened
maybe not you and i but let's say the
artists
we are supposed to be the guardians of
stories
we are supposed to be those who enchant
the world
but for several hundred years now it is
us
who have played the part
in making everything arbitrary
and making everything random
in playing around beauty as if it was
just
a frivolous fantasy
of individuals and so it's partly our
fault
and it's partly our fault as christians
as well
in many ways we have assaulted the world
of meaning
we have assaulted the enchanted world
as christians we in the west
been part of those who have
removed the angels from the heavens
who have chased the sprites out of the
forests
it's us who did that and now we live
with the consequences of our actions
but it hope is not completely lost
we do stand here in a very dark moment
we do stand in a dark room
with strange eerie sounds coming from
that darkness
but all hope is not lost
we know of this story
we know of this story of a man who went
into death
and surprised everybody by entering
there
we know this story of someone who went
into death
and death thought that it had won death
thought that in bringing
that man who was also god into its belly
that it had won
but it grabbed life
and a trick was played on it
and i believe that we can participate
in that trick right now
all of us all of us who are artists
and who believe in that story who live
by that story or at least
have the pretense of living by that
story
there's an opportunity for us
right now because
in this strange darkness
there are strange creepy crawly things
that are coming up
the world is being re-enchanted
the atheists the secularists
they were wrong the world cannot exist
without meaning
it is impossible
every single capacity we have to even
recognize
something as having being is already a
participation in meaning
their war on meaning cannot be won
but as all of our stories have been
shattered and broken apart
it has given rooms for given room for
all the dark things to come back up
first
and those are the things we're starting
to see appear on the
horizon the old gods are coming back and
not even
the interesting old gods but those
darker gods the one that
don't have clear identities those
strange hybrid monsters
that lived on the edge of the world
they're the ones that are crawling back
into the world
first
and as artists we have an opportunity
because we know the story especially
as christian artists we know the story
we know the story of the world we know
what happens
next
there is always a spark hidden in the
darkness
there is always a lit candle in that
darkest place
because without that lit candle things
simply do not
exist the word of god is hidden
in creation and it
is our job
to find it and it is our job
as artists to help the world
see that flicker
and there is an opportunity because a
strange thing is happening in culture
as christianity is being evacuated from
the public sphere
as our story is being tossed aside
it is nonetheless filling the world at
the same time
and this is a mystery that even a few
decades ago people could not see the
strange mystery of death
the strange mystery of christ entering
in the tomb we have
the opportunity of seeing it happen
right now
because as the christian story is being
evacuated
we are noticing that it's reappearing in
all the strangest places
because the bright bright light of
christ is no longer so visible
all of a sudden these small sparkles are
starting to appear
hidden in the cavern walls
and we see the story of christ in the
strangest places we see
some stupid superhero movie where the
superhero
falls to the ground and dies and then
rises again
and we see another strange popular story
coming up of someone
sacrificing themselves for others
giving themselves for the weakest
we see twisted versions of people
who are willing to do everything to
bring up the weaker part of our world
to bolster it and to help it and where
do you think
those lights come from
and so we have an opportunity
but we also have a responsibility
meaning
is inescapable and we have
responsibility towards it
it is a weight that we have to carry as
artists
it is a very daunting responsibility
that we have
right now as the world descends into
darkness that we
are the ones who can give it
a little bit of hope we are the ones
that can point those little sparks
those small lights those twisted
versions
of the true light that we are the ones
who can point it back
to the one true light and origin of our
world
and so i just wanted to maybe
give people uh a challenge
and i know all of you watching this are
probably artists
so i want to give you that challenge
to jump into that story to not think
that the story of christ is
just the story we believe in to be saved
but to truly jump into that story and
realize that that story
is also the story of everything
it is the story of creation this is the
story of how
things exist the story of christ
is the fullest manifestation of every
other
story that have been told since the
beginning of time
and so it is our responsibility to jump
into that
and to redistribute it to the world in
ways that point
towards that great story
so i want to thank you for your
attention today
and i hope that all of us can
grasp that challenge that opportunity
and also that responsibility
[Music]
you